idea of pre-computer signaling policies
that i haven't talked about but you can
read about
and now i want to say something about
comparison with existing methods
uh in our computational study which
involves a very challenging pom dp
problem
um we have we have also
applied existing methods
and these are palm cp and despot
these are general pom dp type methods
involving a
long look ahead but no roll out
long long look ahead with pruning or
monte carlo research
desperate these methods are not well
suited for multiple agents desperate
gave up
at four agents could not solve problems
with four agents
pomcp was able to solve problems with
four ages
no more than four agents but
it gave results that were worse often
worse than
the base policy mod pg is a different
type of method based on policy gradient
ideas and it is applied
it applies to multi-agent problems mypg
just could not cope at all with our
problem it was just doing very strange
things
we worked very hard to make it work but
it simply would not work and would give
you much
worse results from the base policy we
contacted the authors of mark pg to see
what's um
what may be going wrong but
in all indications matt pg cannot solve
this type of multi robot repair problems
and not only that it doesn't do sensible
things at all
um so uh
you i'll i'll leave you with that and
you can read the computational results
from the paper that's posting my website
and uh
i welcome your questions i'm sorry about
the
taking over thank you so much for that
talk and um i think one thing i know
it's always
uh personally frustrating when i don't
have enough time to share some of the
results i'm excited about so if you
wouldn't mind
if you have a link to the longer talk if
it's been pre-recorded we could put that
in the chat messages and that will also
give a nice pointer to people who
can see the the full the full version um
because we can make sure all the
attendees see that too
yeah everything is uh at my website and
if one goes at my website which they
should have no difficulty
um there's a there's a link to the new
book and also to
my earlier book on reinforcement
learning and
uh everything is very clearly given
there all the papers including
and and the youtube one-hour talk
um that's wonderful
do you mind um stopping sharing your
screen please so that um nathan can
um set up his share my screen i thought
it was
can you stop sharing your screen um
because that way the next person can
start set up
so from one mit connection to another um
we're next gonna be having nathan callus
who did his phd at mit
um i give a talk nathan is now an
assistant professor over at cornell tech
um who spans a number of different
really interesting research areas he's
won multiple awards including an nsf
career award
um and we're excited to hear what he has
to say today about statistical
efficiency in offline rl which might
also connect to what peng was talking
about earlier today
thanks it will uh thanks emma thanks for
the introduction and thanks to all the
organizers for organizing
inviting me uh it's a pleasure to be
here so i'll be talking about a series
of uh
of papers that's uh that are joined with
my student
masa on the theme of statistical
efficiency in
offline rl and the motivation uh
for the work is is largely the potential
for
using reinforcement learning in medical
applications so one example of that
may be sepsis which is when the body has
a
an extreme reaction to uh to an
infection and
the organs start shutting down and it's
a leading cause of death worldwide but
despite having this very morbid status
it's really not clear how what's the
best way to manage sepsis
and to treat patients in a dynamic way
largely because there's a lot a lot of
different interventions that a doctor
can take they can apply vessel
suppressors
give out your fluids take away iv fluids
and there's potentially a lot of
heterogeneity and how that might
impact different patients and their very
subtle symptoms
so maybe this is a great opportunity for
reinforcement learning you know maybe
too many patterns for
humans to process but maybe a machine
can
do well here of course in such
high-stakes domains uh exploration is
going to be
uh very limited uh we can't just go out
and apply vessel suppressors
or take them away just just to see what
happens and we have to take care with
every action that we take so in these
settings
we really have to rely on existing data
like ehrs has
as has been uh mentioned this week in
this
excellent workshop um the
important thing is so there's a lot of
this data out there
but we have to take care to use it
correctly uh so
so one example of uh of doing offline
rail in medicine
is this nature medicine uh paper that
proposed
this uh the algorithm they call the air
clinician where they took ehr data
electronic health records
from an icu so this was observational
data they used the mimic data set
and they applied rel to it uh
specifically to to train an algorithm to
treat sepsis
uh but this was actually met with quite
a bit of scrutiny and skepticism
from both the reinforcement learning and
medical communities
and you know there's a lot of discussion
there but
in my summary i think one of the biggest
gripes was essentially that
a lot of this was highly unreliable due
to what's known as the curse of verizon
so what komorowski adel did to evaluate
how the algorithm was doing
uh was important sampling and rejection
and poor sampling so it would go
something like this
each patient in their data set they
would see
what their algorithm did for example in
the beginning did it apply
mechanical ventilation or not and if it
agreed with the observation
they kept the the observation if it
didn't they threw it away uh they did
the same
later on down this down the line you
know did we apply sedation our algorithm
would apply sedation
did the data set uh did the day points
have sedation at this point
no throw it away and so on and so forth
and you know the immediate thing
to see is that as the horizon grows as
there's more opportunities to think
about
actions uh that we would take versus
what happened in the data
the the amount of data is going to
whittle down into absolutely nothing in
a geometric way
so the aim of the
talk that i'm going to give today is to
try to think about well how can we
overcome these
fundamental limits by leveraging problem
structure
in particular macovian structure or time
and variance structure or ergotic
structure
and essentially the theme of how i'm
going to tackle this is
you know we only have the data that we
have in offline reinforcement learning
we can't go out and collect more that is
the definition of the problem
so we better use it to its moses we
better use it efficiently but actually
if you think about
what efficient means well that's going
to depend on the problem structure and
as we change the structure
what efficient is changes and we can
actually see at what point
do we get past these limitations at what
point is the lower bound better
than what we wanted at what point is the
lower round telling us that everything
is hopeless
so what i'm going to do is what we've
done in these series of papers is study
the efficiency limits in a variety of
offline reinforcement learning tasks
in the mdp model for the first time
and this gave us insight into when the
curse of horizon bites because
we can see what the limit is and uh
and if the limit is too high then
there's no hope and this really paints
this
as a problem-dependent phenomenon it
depends on the problem and what you
assume about it not an
estimated dependent phenomenon um it's
it's just a question of achieving this
bound
so after studying these limits i'm also
going to
provide the first efficient estimators
for both policy value and policy
gradient estimation from off policy data
in the mdp model in both finite and
infinite horizon settings
and there was a little mention about um
about don's current entropy conditions
earlier so these actually will be remain
efficient even when we are going to
estimate the distances at slow rates
using blackboard machine learning making
no entropy assumptions on them
uh so in outline of the talk um
and unfortunately i think since i
started like i'm going to
eat into the break but i'll try to
minimize that
um and so i'll start by
setting up the problem and defining some
of my notation
and describing what efficient means and
uh and efficiency here will be kind of
the
uh the instance the specific
uh bounds that martin uh mentioned on
the first day when he was talking about
lacam's theory
and it's related to what peng was
talking about and then i'll present our
results on the efficiency bounds and how
these limits change as we change the
structure
and then i'll talk about how we can
actually achieve these bounds
using an algorithm that we call double
reinforcement learning
which is a riff on the double machine
learning uh
name and then i'll so i'll talk first
about
that in the context of off policy
evaluation then i'll switch gears to
talk a little bit about off policy
gradient estimation because there's some
interesting unique things that happen
there
and we can talk also about implications
for policy learning
in that case and then if there's time
also talk about some experimental
results
so the working model for reinforcement
learning is the markov decision process
the mdp
i certainly don't need to define this
for this audience but it'll use the
opportunity
uh to tell you about my notation so
we're all on the same page so we're
going to have an agent for example
the doctor observe the state of the
environment the environment here being
for example the patient
and based on this state she's going to
act according to
some policies the policy is simply going
to be a distribution over actions given
current state
and in reaction to this uh
action the state is going to advance so
the environment is going to advance to a
new state which is described by this
transition probability which depends on
the current state and the action we took
in it and it's also going to emit a
reward that depends on the current state
and the action that we took in it
uh and if you think about it if you take
the mdp part right what's the problem
the problem is defined by
the state and reward probability because
that defines the environment and you
combine it with a policy what are we
going to do in every state how is the
agent acting
then if these are just two different
sets of probabilities if you multiply
them together
essentially what this induces is a joint
distribution
over the random variables given by state
action reward
state action reward state action reward
okay so we have these random variables
um and this is going to give us a joint
distribution over them and they're going
to satisfy this
this essentially causal dag uh encoding
the independencies
encoded by the markov assumptions
and what we want is just to maximize
reward so we're going to look at the
average reward
uh over time so average from t equals 0
to t of the reward that we see
and we can weight it by a discount
factor gamma and we can also look at the
long run average reward which is when we
take t going to infinity so ope
is just a task of for given a policy pi
that we care about we want to estimate
its reward
but the data that we get is from is n
observations of t
long trajectories uh from playing the
mdp with a different policy pipe and the
behavior policy may be no no unknown
i'll focus on known uh but actually the
efficiency results don't don't change
whether it's unknown the key difficulty
here is that the
estimate the thing we want to estimate
is an expectation one expectation
under one probability distribution but
the data is coming from a different
probability distribution so we can't
just take sample averages
that's for evaluation what about
learning well then
in this case we suppose we're given a uh
parametrized policy class parameterized
by this
policy parameter theta and we're gonna
we
simplify the notation simply say value
at theta is the value of pi theta
and then the off policy gradient is the
problem of estimating the gradient
of the policy value given and
observations of t long trajectories from
a different policy
now we can use this common trick
of the rewriting the policy gradient in
terms of the policy score
which is the gradient of the log of the
policy
and we can rewrite the gradient again as
just an expectation so now there's we
don't have to
this gradient operator is built into the
policy score which is just a function of
our policy
again the difficulty is this is
expectation about with respect to one
distribution
the data is coming from a different
distribution why care about policy
gradients
uh policy gradient methods have driven a
lot of the successes recently in
reinforcement learning
whether it's playing video games or
moving a robotic hand to to solve the
rubik's cubes
to solve the rubik's cube that's of
course in the setting
we can explore and simulate but
hopefully
that is will tell us that maybe here
there's also potential for policy
gradient methods
so a very very very brief overview of
some existing
approaches to these problems and this is
kind of a very minimal overview i don't
mean to you know detract to minimize any
of the things i'm not mentioning
i'm just trying to give the flavor of
some of these things to be uh
self-contained to some amount so
maybe the simplest thing you could do
for op is the sequential importance
sampling
estimator which is simply the following
we're going to take the cumulative
density ratio which is the product
of the ratio between the
target policy and the behavior policy
the behavior policies of course the one
that's
generating the data and what this lambda
t does is essentially just change method
measures from the distribution under pi
b to the distribution under the target
policy
so then we can construct an estimator
simply given by taking the
empirical expectations when i say e sub
n i mean
1 over n sum over i of this quantity
where each
thing here is going to be applied to the
if data point
and because the data is coming from pi b
this expectation
is going to look asymptotically like
expectation like a population
expectation with respect to p pi b
we put these lambdas here so that we're
actually changing to the target
distribution we want so that's what
important sampling does
we can add a control variable to this
and this leads to what's known as the w
robust estimator and the reason i'm
putting it in code is because
there's a lot of things that are doubly
robust we're going to talk about other
things that are w robust
but in the context of ope this
particular estimator has been
dubbed the w of assessment so that's why
i'm calling that the dr estimator
and here we just take the ss estimator
we add a control variant
one example of adding of a control vary
is the q function
so the q function is the expected
rewards to go
if we're following the target policy and
we're currently in state
st and we're going to take action 80.
you can either think about it as a
function of sdit or as a random variable
that's measurable respect to
the random variable's sd80 here we
estimate q
hat t and plug it in uh of course if
we're in the infinite horizon setting
q is independent of t there's a lot of
variants of this which
are essentially looking at different
ways of choosing the control vary
rather than plug-in ways maybe some
optimal ways or some
shrinking ways and there's different
benefits to these but i won't have time
to talk about that aspect of the problem
uh and then for off policy gradients
there is
methods again doing important sampling
uh
just take the expectation to define the
policy gradient add lambdas
change to empirical expectation this is
sometimes called reinforce
uh there's also a way to rewrite it
using queue functions this
leads to an estimator called off pack
and a super naive view of the curse of
verizon we're going to be a bit more
technical later
is that even if the policy
the target policy is such that the ratio
between uh
the target policy and the behavioral
policy is roughly constant
um so it's in some sense bounded right
if these are the same policies this will
be one if there are different policies
this will be sometimes smaller than one
sometimes bigger than one
so i mean like a moment is roughly c
uh then we'll have that these lambdas
are going to grow exponentially
all these estimators have lambda in them
so they will all
have variances exposed exponentially and
will have infinite variance
in the infinite horizon setting
quick quick quick mention of some other
things we could do we could just
do the direct method using q then we can
just bake in the mtp structure into the
queue model
there's also methods recently looking at
different kinds of important sampling
using stationary or marginalized density
ratios
and these leverage mdp structure uh
which is
great and makes a dent in this problem
and it motivates our current study you
know definitely
want to give credit what credit is due
but these are still not efficient
uh in general that means they will have
a sub-optimal leading constant
in their variance but more generally
these will actually
in non-tabular non-parametric settings
this will actually generally have a slow
rate
because these estimates we're going to
need to
estimate like q we won't be able to get
parametric rates there so these
this bad rate will then influence the
rate of these
so what do we mean when we say
efficiency what are we going to try
and get to so again very abridged
description of what this means just
enough to
tell you about our results so
efficiency goes like this we suppose we
have a model which is
simply just a set of distributions for
the data that's what a model is
okay we have a parameter of interest
which is just some aspect of the data
generating distribution
some function of it then we fix
the data generating distribution which
is an object of the
model and the data that we see is id
observations
from it what we want is we want a good
estimator which is a function of the
data
for this true parameter which is a
function of p and of course we want to
use the data to the mostest
one of the big punchlines of same
parametric efficiency theory says that
any estimator
is going to work for all instances in
the model okay or technically
is a regular estimator if it's going to
work for all estimators then for
e sorry if it's going to work for all
instances then for
each specific instance it also has to
satisfy this lower bound
where if we look at the mean squared
error
of the estimate we scale it by n the
limit in feminine is going to be lower
bounded by this quantity called the
efficiency bound
which is given by the two norm of what's
known as the efficient influence
function which is the least norm
derivative
of tau when we take derivatives respect
to the dgp
in the model and actually i just want to
correct something that
peng said peng was actually when he gave
the definition for a regular estimate he
actually gave the definition for
asymptotically linear which is different
and the difference is actually really
important between regular and
asymptotically linear
because asymptotically linear is an
instance specific property
and regular is a model dependent
property and
efficiency depends on the model because
in some sense you want an estimator
that works for all things near the
instance in the model
so those things are actually different
and they only coincide
in the case of an efficient estimator
but it's important to distinguish from
them
if you're going to define what
efficiency means um so how do we apply
this to our problem
can i just interrupt you for a second
could you just go to the pad and answer
a couple questions from ravi
about the change of measure um yeah can
you tell me about the questions uh
yeah so the question about the there
should be at the bottom of the zoom
um a q a but if you can't i'm happy to
do it so ravi
in terms of the change of measure um
like a radon uh
nicodem uh derivative yes exactly um in
terms of the non-parametric
um uh tispa gov i said that wrong
so what what is the question the
question does this requires an absolute
continuity between the target policy
and the behavior policy that's correct
all right thanks robbie was that the
question i i believe so but um it's not
so uh robbie i'll promote you to being
um
so that you can ask additional chat
messages um or jump in uh live if you'd
like to
so let's keep going and then we'll jump
in with additional questions
okay thank you so how do we apply this
definition of efficiency to our problem
well for us the target estimate is going
to be the policy value
or the policy gradient and what's the
model well the model is going to be
the model is the dgp where is our data
coming from our data is coming from
trajectories
from the behavioral policy that's p pi b
so the model is the set of
all such distributions when we vary
the mvp problem okay so if pi b is known
that's going to stay fixed and we're
going to vary the the mvp arbitrarily
and essentially to be regular would mean
to work for md for the mdp model
but it's actually going to be quite
insightful to look at other models
that are larger than the mdp model
corresponding to larger efficiency
bounds in order to understand
what are we gaining so in particular
we're going to consider
three nested models so the markov
decision process model is at the bottom
is the one i described so
far we can actually make the transition
reward and action probabilities time
dependent so that's going to lead to
something
called a time varying mdp or tmvp model
we can also let the transitions reward
and actually depend on the whole history
of state in actions in in a sense we're
dropping the markovian assumption so i'm
going to call it the non-markov decision
process or nmdp right so if we
make a line here at s1 the bottom two
models
decompose but the top one does not
so what happens in these different
models
so to avoid having to define a lot of
different
notation for different importance
sampling ratios etc
i'm just going to give you the punchline
of the
efficiency balance results that we have
and
just to kind of drive things to the
hardest
limit i'm going to look at the infinite
horizon of policy evaluation or off
policy gradient uh problems the
the the rates here i'm going to show the
same uh so the setting is we've
observed n trajectories of length t from
pi b and we want to estimate the long
run infinite horizon uh reward for a
given target policy so first in the nmdp
what you can show is that if these
density ratios
are sufficiently big so they should be
bigger than one over gamma
in particular if they have just this log
moment that's bigger than one over gamma
then the efficiency bound under the nmdp
model is just infinity there's just no
way you can beat this okay so this is
means we must suffer from the curse of
horizon there's no way around this
any estimator that works in the nmdp
model including
the existing estimators i talked about
in the beginning must
suffer from this on the other hand if
this cumulative density ratio actually
is
not growing exponentially in gamma
then you can get a finite efficiency
bound
and the msc will scale something like
one over n one over the number of
trajectories
okay but essentially this is like saying
that these ratios
are bounded by one over gamma so if
gamma is 0.9 it means
bounded by like 1.1 which is essentially
like saying you're in the on policy
setting so that's why i put a little
video game character on this it's
essentially like on policy
uh policy evaluation
what happens if we impose the markovian
structure if we oppose the macovian
structure
we can still have this finite efficiency
bound and efficiently scan like 1 over n
if instead the cumulative density ratio
just its marginalization respect to st
and 80
is not growing too fast and this is a
much more lack
condition in fact you can show that this
condition must hold and actually this is
going to be big
o of 1 if we're in a setting where the
transition and and and reward and the
action probabilities are all time
independent then you necessarily will
have this is kind of bounded by one
but if you're going to assume that then
you're assuming in the mdp model
but you're using the tmdp efficiency
balance this is essentially just a
crappy bound for the assumptions that
you're making
if you're going to assume mdp you should
ask to be efficient in the mdp model
so what's efficient in the mdp model is
actually
not just a lower constant here in front
but it's actually a different rate
altogether in the ndp model every
transition
every state action reward state
observation
is informative so really the scaling
should be one over
n times t which is the number of
observations that we see and
you can you should be able to get this
even if you have just a single
trajectory of growing length
as long as you're assuming some
organicity about this single trajectory
sorry oh sorry uh could you explain a
little bit about the ergodicity
assumption like um
yeah i have a um background in math
yeah so essentially yeah yeah so we we
have we want to assume that the
uh we'll need to assume that the markov
chain induced on state action reward
by either the evaluation or uh or
behavior policies
it has to be harris ergodic and of
course they
there's also the the assumption that
these rotis
exist and have an even l2 moment
which is kind of an assumption in in
here as well
oh this is sort of a existing assumption
you haven't changed that part of the
assumption
right right i i glossed over it right
that i think that was the question i
don't know if this is
the same person who asked the question
before right but by assuming these exist
this is assuming that we're done they
can
nicotine derivative exist which is
saying they're absolutely uh continuous
but
um also for right this is going to be
msc
so these they also have to have an l2
moment
so have to be an l2 variable l2 moment
for the which for which moment of the
gradient
no roti oh bro okay yeah
i think we might need to just gift in
time i want to make sure nathan has a
few more minutes to go through the rest
of his talk somebody don't we hold
additional
um questions on the technical details
which are very important but let's just
postpone those together
and i'll be connected during the break
and happy to to stay on and chat
uh with anybody who's interested to ask
more questions um
okay so i put this money face
emoji here because this looks great we
want to cash in on this awesome
rate how do we do that okay
so for that i'm going to present first
i'm going to focus on the case of
op and i'm going to present the double
reinforcement learning algorithm
before i delve into a specific instance
of it right where there's a lot of cases
that we consider in these places
in is in these papers so just to give an
overview of what's the nature of the
results
so here's essentially what we do
for each of these cases so for each of
the cases being whether we're looking at
mdp tmdp and mdp
whether we're looking at the off policy
evaluation or policy gradient problem
whether we're looking at fine or
infinite horizon what we do is we derive
the efficient influence function for
each one of them
right and that's the least norm gradient
of the estimate
which plays the crucial role in the
efficiency bound
and all of these eafs are going to
involve some nuisances so in particular
they're all going to look like
some function phi which is going to have
expectation tau
minus tau and phi depends on the
nuisances that
write something that depends on the dgp
script
p so the nuisance is actually changed by
case but one thing that is an example in
all of these cases is the q
function in all these cases one of the
new systems is going to be the q
function
so if we did know the nuisances we could
just take a simple average of this phi
and that will by definition be an
efficient estimator but of course we
don't know it
so one idea is estimate these things
like estimate the q function
plug it in take empirical expectations
so that kind of works we have to make
sure it works and we have to kind of
tweak this
so first for this to hopefully even work
we
have to prove some properties about the
efficient influence functions so we
proved that they satisfy certain double
robustness
properties so in the case of ope there's
going to be two nuisances
so i'm going to call them eta 1 eta 2.
generically one of them is q
and actually if you just plug in the
correct data 1 but anything for eta 2
or the correct data 2 and anything for
801 they will still be
unbiased for tao and there's a slightly
different interesting case for opg
i hope we'll get to talk about it so
this essentially shows
that taking pair expectations of phi is
really insensitive to errors in ada hat
as long as it's sufficient close to ada
there's something known as neman
orthogonality
so then to leverage this what we can do
is we could use
cross-fitting cross-fold fitting to
estimate these ada hats
so i'll explain this in a specific
example in the next slide
and this is a technique that's been
coined as
double machine learning in a recent
paper veterinarian
and what this does is allows us to use
very flexible machine learning
estimators without making
any conditions on these estimators okay
and again there's going to be some
interesting special case that
differentiates
from how cross-fold fitting is done in
double ml due to the problem that we
have one long trajectory with dependent
data
so let me give you an example so let's
look at infinite horizon
uh ope uh in
an mvp model and if you had many
trajectories you could just use two
folds
but let's look at the one trajectory
case because it's kind of interesting
suppose we have a single trajectory of
length t and
t is growing here so we're getting more
and more data because this trajectory is
growing
so what we do is we're going to split it
into four folds
okay d0 d1 d3 d2 so i kind of numbered
it a little bit funny
you'll see in a second why numbered it
this way
then what we're going to do is first
let's define
w to be the ratio between two things one
is the gamma discounted average
visitation distribution
under the target policy and divided by
the
undiscounted stationary distribution
under the behavior policies this is
slightly different from
leodoll where they actually use the same
kind of discounting
but actually the the thing that comes
out from the efficiency analysis
is this ratio because the data that we
see is not discounted but the evaluation
we want to do is respect to a
discounted distribution so then what
we're going to do we're going to look at
each one of these
four folds and in each one using just
data inside that fold we're going to
construct estimators for this w
and for the q function using only data
in here
and i put a star here because it didn't
really tell you how to construct these
estimators yet but
use some black box magic use only the
data here construct an estimator
and then we're going to set our
estimator to be the
average the time average over the
trajectory
of this function phi which is coming
from the efficiency analysis
which depends on state action rewards
state
next state so we're going to feed it all
of the all of the transitions that we
observe
and it depends on w and q so when we're
looking at a
transition in let's say d3 we're going
to use the nuisances estimated on d0
when averaging on a transition inside d1
we're going to use a nuisance from d2
and the crucial thing here is we want
the transition to
look independent from the data that we
use to fit these nuisances
and the reason we split into four when
we have a dependent
uh trajectory is that as this trajectory
grows
under sufficient ergodicity we're going
to have that for example
this d3 segment is going to grow so d1
is going to be farther from d2
so they're going to look more and more
independent in particular we can
show that if we assume certain ergicity
conditions and if each one of these
nuisances is fit
at a rate alpha 1 for q alpha 2 for w
then if these alphas sum to at least a
half and we have some mixing conditions
on the data
then our estimator is going to be
asymptotically normal and efficient it's
an
asymptotic variance will be controlled
by the efficiency then and the key
feature of such a result
is that we're making no assumptions of
these nuisance estimators just a slow
rate okay so we don't need to impose
downstream conditions
if we didn't use cost fold fitting we
can still do this by imposing credential
conditions and the rates can for example
be slower than parametric that is one
half rates it could be a quarter
or anything that satisfies this
trade-off over here
and nathan i'm sorry we'll need to wrap
in about a minute okay so i'll just skip
the
the opg section i'll finish this and
i'll conclude thanks emma
um so we can also uh show a certain
double robustness guarantee that
just it's enough for each one of these
estimates to be consistent
uh for the estimated to consistent so
essentially if each one of these circles
represents where one of these models is
consistent
then we're consistent anywhere in this
union and we're efficient
when both are consistently estimated at
slow rates
and some example cases of this so
for example if you're in the tabular
setting in
mdp or tmdp that is if the state and
action spaces are finite
we can obtain parametric rates for all
the instances because they're all
essentially parametric and then we get
efficiency we don't even need to use
cross-fold
uh fitting in a finite state space with
a known behavior policy and a tmdp
this paper shed all actually provides
parametric rates for the marginalized
density ratio so we only need
to get uh consistency for the queue
estimate absolutely no rate
so just using kernel regression
estimates here will suffice
here as long as q is bounded which is
enough to just assume rewards are
bounded in order to get boundedness so
again you immediately get efficiency
right the game here is once you have the
submitted estimator how do we get the
nuisances to satisfy the conditions
in the general non-perimeter case you
could use general
flexible machine learning estimates you
would just need to get something with
the rate
we're making no further restrictions on
them such as donsk or other entropy
conditions
so for example you can use dual dice or
the other dice papers
to estimate w more generally than that w
and q are both
just quantities that are defined by
conditional moment restrictions
so you can use some classic theory on
solving non-parametric
conditional moment restrictions or a
recent proposal
that i was involved in of actually
solving these with neural nets using
adversarial training so these can
for example help you get you know more
machine learning the
neural net estimates for w and q
and there's a variety of other results
in the paper about efficiency in the
other models find the sample guarantees
inefficiency of other estimators etc
and unfortunately i won't be able to
tell you too much about
off policy gradient gradients
and i'll skip the experimental results
and i'll just kind of
summarize about what was the point of
this well we wanted to overcome these
fundamental limits in offline
reinforcement learning
and the key was to leverage problem
structure because if we don't assume
anything we got nothing
and we're going to be hit by the curse
of horizon any uh no matter what we do
there's
not an estimated dependent thing it's
problem dependent in order to get past
this
we have to impose structure so we study
the efficiency limits in
off policy evaluation and of policy
grading estimation
for the first time in the mdp model and
we provided uh the first efficient
estimators for this
so that's it i'll end here thanks
thanks for the great talk and um i am
sorry that there was
it would always be great to hear more
from all of the speakers um uh
i'll let everyone go to the break in
just a second um but i'll first see if
there are any questions people wanted to
raise
immediately um so one person did ask um
the idea is to split the data to make
them independent correct um what is the
property of the data in one group i'm
assuming it's just
you know a random split but uh i'll let
you comment
uh so it's not a random split it has to
be according to the time index because
we want d2 to look independent of d1 etc
because this d3 is going to grow make
these two segments of the trajectory
separated
so essentially think about that picture
before about
s-a-r-s-a-r-s-a-r this is essentially
what these little boxes are boxing in
so it's boxing in those transitions in
the case where you have more than one
trajectory like even if you have just
two trajectories it's enough to just
split it into two folds uh you just need
to
make sure that you're independent um
and notice that you don't get a t
deterioration
in the rate that it's like n over two or
sorry in the constant you don't get like
the two and the constant
because you're still averaging uh over
all folds
every fold plays both roles of nuisance
estimation
and a transition that we average over
yeah i was thinking about the episodic
case where you'd split randomly on the
transitions where that would
be sufficient but yes for a long
trajectory
yeah you have to make sure you've got
the independence yeah and i guess one
other quick question i'll ask um
uh before we break is um i think that
the theoretical results here are really
exciting and it's great
sort of the generic types of nuisance
parameters what's your sense of whether
or not this will lead to
um sort of impact on empirical estimates
um i know we didn't give you a chance to
talk about those so either that would be
a chance to
flash up a slide or to talk more
generally of whether or not you think
these insights
will lead to sort of more more efficient
and therefore like more accurate
means quarter estimates absolutely so
you know in some sense what i shoved
under the rug in this is the nuisance
estimation right
i just said if you have sufficiently
fast nuisance estimators
um but i think in practice i would still
opt for something orthogonalized like
this
even if they weren't consistent even if
i was using you know
i think earlier i think it was you i
mean you mentioned this example you know
well who knows if a two-layer neural net
is well specified
so theoretically of course you could
grow the neural net
uh deeper and wider and that actually
can achieve many max rates that's kind
of like
this result uh by sanjay misra max
farrell and the
third author who you know very
embarrassingly
i'm not remembering their name they give
kind of you know what are the rays
that you get for doing this and it's
some sort of assumption about how much
smoothness you have
but again that's purely theoretical when
you're going and applying the sepsis
who knows what the smoothness is but i
think this
is still giving us insight and telling
us well you should not
just do um direct modeling you should
not just
do important sampling that will be
extremely sensitive
to the whatever it is that you devise
whether it's a two-layer uh neural
network or something
you know much more complex like a very
deep neural net
you should combine uh these things in
order to be orthogonal to this error
that's essentially what
this property tells us we want to be
insensitive to errors in
a hat even if we can't guarantee these
race to prove these theorems
so i definitely think this is kind of a
it's a meta algorithm and to get some
results about efficiency you have to
invoke
smoothness and to show certain rates but
i also think it's a
recipe for applying this in practice
where you should
aim for insensitivity to errors in your
nuisance estimates
if i if i can ask one question about
you're talking about smoothness
like um so does it require i didn't
understand if you meant that it required
smoothness like you wanted to be the you
want your data you want somehow
you were actually actively smoothing
like you're you're convolving with
gaussians
or you're actually you're you you're
actually saying you should be
resistant to smoothness so that you
should get as low
regularity as possible like maybe even
like non-differentiable
like crazy regularity yeah just let me
just enjoy it before just to say
let's you know continue absolutely
continue the discussions just as a quick
reminder for people that might have to
pop off
grab coffee and come back um a reminder
that we'll be starting again in about 10
minutes with the next speaker um and so
nathan thank you so much and ravi go
ahead
yeah so so there is no smoothing here
right the
the estimator is just this thing